hell gang mozzie tapping in you already
know man make sure y'all tap in tune in
bootleg here podcast [ __ ] thuggin
podcast special guest in here my brother
you know i had to pull up that was
mandated
my guy man good to see you ready hey
listen man i just ate some shrooms so
we'll see how this goes
we'll see how it goes
you know what i'm saying hey good to see
you man first of all congratulations on
um the cmg situation
um
i feel like uh you have been kind of
like art our uh champion here on the
west coast
in terms of just like who i feel like
you know if i had to bet all the all the
[ __ ] money push it in on the middle
of the table would be on you for a long
time man so it's good to see um
i guess like the rest of the industry
kind of catch on if that makes sense
yeah a little tardy we ain't worried
about it though we most definitely i'm
saying i ain't gonna lie like just this
whole
experience you know that's my first time
i mean signing or even going in that
direction
i've been independent to the necklace
um and so i just wanted to see what this
machine do so i'm excited to see what it
do yeah for you like um like you said
you've been in indy for so long um
what were the things that were important
for you to like finally
cross the other side of the island and
go the major route uh first and foremost
i wanted to establish like a catalogue i
wanted catalog i wanted to be you know i
wanted to own my own catalog before i
crossed over
and um
i wanted to make sure i was fine
financially legitimate right i ain't
gonna go over there and then you know
next thing you know i got all type of
complaints because i feel like you know
i ain't received a check in
some odd months or you feel me i'm just
you know this just discomfort i wanted
to be comfortable when i when i finally
made my move uh shut out the net you
know just following his marathon
and uh his outlook on this whole thing
but uh yeah i just wanted to be
comfortable and i wanted to you know i
ain't wanted to i didn't want to be
forced and i wanted to have a little
leverage i wanted to be able to um yeah
kind of customize my deal and uh make
sure it made sense yeah because i think
most artists they sign too soon and then
they end up complaining on instagram
about the record lane
come on
so for sure um how long like how long
has it been since gotti like originally
reached out we've been [ __ ] around
being [ __ ] around bobby brown uh you
know we didn't have and sat down on
multiple occasions um
i'm talking about years back
and uh like i said i just wasn't
comfortable at the time i was really
i was ecstatic at the way that my career
was going you know independent route for
me to be able to
i'm seeing me really log in and see my
numbers
um that empire back end is nice you get
to log in yeah yeah receiving the
monthly checks
um and just feeling like i had control
of my own career so uh that was dope but
i just feel like right now is the time
right now is the time i want that
injection i want that little power boost
have you noticed um maybe like
people who maybe weren't embracing you
before kind of come around now that you
got you know that i mean because looks
and if we're being honest god he's got
the highest label in the game right now
i don't think anybody would dispute that
um the team is crazy i ain't really
noticed a lot um cause everybody being
genuinely functioning with me so uh it
ain't too many people like jumping on
the bandwagon or nothing like that
uh
and then you know i ain't i ain't really
been traveling lately to where i could
see
i'm seeing a difference right right
right right media going a different [ __ ]
right right so uh it's been everything
as you know as it's been as is um
but uh
i've been getting a lot of
congratulations a lot of congratulations
everywhere i go congratulations
congratulations congratulations and uh
so you know that alone let me know that
that was a good move on my behalf and um
i'm just excited i'm excited to drop the
album see what it does
and just establishing this relationship
continue to build
i'm saying put the pieces together and
uh press play uh talk about like uh
obviously
you're a boss dave's a boss you guys
have built this empire
um
but for when it comes to just your
labels um
you know i feel like you've kind of laid
the blueprint for a lot of artists to
follow too as much as nipsey did you
know what i'm saying um
what are some things you guys have
learned from yo gotti just being
you know he's a boss too man he just
bought a [ __ ] soccer team right you
know what i'm saying like what are some
things that you've already soaked up in
terms of just on
from being you know you're our ceo
yourself you know what i mean yeah just
being like you said on on a in a in a
boss aspect
um
i like the way you just kind of fall
back and i'm saying that's as far back
and and put the put the light on his
artist that's kind of like what i want
to do eventually where i get to a point
where you know i feel like i gotta maxed
out musically i'm saying me i tamper
with it dibble and dabble with it but
really put the the spotlight on my
artist and use my platform in a in that
manner you know anything that i got
going on as far as instagram is
concerned or outside of instagram he
immediately bruh send that to me let me
throw that up and uh you know just being
independent we throw everything up it's
it's very rare that i'm seeing me we got
like somebody that's pumping it pumping
it and so uh
you know i just love the way that he he
he involved in everything
um
sitting in the meetings
you know
we take a meeting he take a meeting
um
and it just inspired me as far as like
everything that i want to do with my
artist futuristically you know right now
i'm kind of like super focused on myself
and i'm seeing me just creating a
pathway so they could uh follow suit but
um
eventually i want to get to a point
where you know i fall back off a rat and
uh just really run my label and uh just
tweak on everything outside of rap and
you know he got a lot a lot of good game
a lot of good game of ism every time we
said hell yeah i'm saying it's like i'm
taking notes a lot of good game ism um
how much of this new album did you just
already have done and brought to the
table and how much of it was like
what's the deal once the fine print
dried up they had like 20 done
probably had like 20 percent done that's
how i feel
uh i thought i had 50 done yeah i'm
saying as soon as we locked in i thought
it was fifty percent done but when i
when i got back in that booth and you
know just catching a
i don't want to say second win just a
burst of inspiration all right i'm
saying uh
i realized that you know i wouldn't i
probably use like three four songs out
of the ten that i had done before
signing i mean every time i go in there
and create new songs they become my
favorite songs and so it kind of like
bumped it bumped the other songs off and
i'm saying so things that was supposed
to make the album probably ain't gonna
make the album just because of the new
songs the more i create
i'm saying
your output is very high too man like
you know what i'm saying when it comes
to just having records and recording man
like
most definitely now that's one of my i
think that's one of the hardest parts of
all this is just creating music and then
thinking you got it you got it down
and then you know you look up and you
got 30 songs and you only got it you got
you know usually i pick like 12 15.
um i think i'm gonna go a little further
then i'm gonna go a little further on
this one probably like 18 20 but um you
know even to knock 10 songs off and all
of them mean something to me very
valuable whether it's therapeutic
whether it's inspirational whether it's
just heartfelt songs that i feel like
deserve to be on the album some of them
ain't gonna make it and uh so you know
that's like the hardest part is just
picking the songs in a you know
cultivating album it's crazy uh when i
first met you it was like 2016 or 17.
i don't know if you remember you came up
to the radio station with like 40 people
oh it was a gangster party huh it was
the largest entourage i've ever had show
up to an interview
that sounds like me that sounds like it
was i was like god everyone had a mozzie
chain i said jesus [ __ ] brought
the whole hood with him we brought all
sacramento with him most definitely
that's how i was moving um i still kind
of move like that as far as a show
concern i just try to get everybody the
opportunity to touch this well i was
gonna say like i feel like i've
witnessed your evolution just as a man
too like i feel like you obviously have
matured a lot in terms of just
you know how you move around um
i don't see you in places i might have
seen you in before you know what i mean
like most definitely was there a moment
where you realized like
you gotta kind of adjust how you're
moving
because you mean a lot to a lot of
people nah for certainly um
you know i just feel like uh if it ain't
beneficial it's artificial
if uh if it ain't a paid event i ain't
got no business there you feel me um i
feel like
you know uh
we can't fumble we too close to the td
the fumble we can't be fumbling i'm
saying and you know just moving
sporadically you're gonna fumble you
most definitely go fumble out here slimy
is treacherous
and uh i'm saying we just trying to
protect the bag as well as the brand so
just protecting the bag protecting the
brand and i'm saying um
you know and
uh the way that these people are
operating is guilty by association so
you know uh if you got a lot of ignorant
foolish people who don't care or ain't
got nothing to lose and i'm saying and
who who don't see the vision like you
see it they'll throw it all away for you
and i'm seeing me so it's like we got to
check them at the doe
and just move more strategically more
militant
yeah it's hot out here too man it's sure
it's it's harder i just saw there was
that shooting in sacramento that uh what
made national headlines was that i was
at the mall right uh downtown semis and
foot down there in front of the capitol
[ __ ] is crazy that's for sure how often
do you like because obviously we think
of guys like dolph who passed away in
their hometown nipsey uh and we go down
the list man xxx uh
like i know you go back home a lot but
like
is it is it becoming like harder and
harder for you to like
go home
nah cause it's right down the street
it's only a couple hours down the street
and um
you know uh like i said we're just
moving militant i ain't going home to
hang out on the block and
and thug and you know jeopardize
everything we didn't build i'm going
home to touch my people i'm pulling up
on the ones i love dearly the ones that
i'm seeing me that mean something to me
the ones who've been rooting for me
since day one so you know i touch down
make sure i touch everybody that i'm
supposed to touch and then uh it's back
to the baggage claim and they completely
understand they get it they damn they'll
be rushing me out the city right right
right right so
um
yeah that's it so you know i i double
back double back frequently touch the
ones i love i you like you said it's a
lot of maturity a lot of growth so it
ain't like a [ __ ] on some young [ __ ]
[ __ ] where [ __ ] touch [ __ ] get home
[ __ ] on live [ __ ] i'm saying on the
corner where i'm at out here and i'm not
that's right we it's a lot more a lot
more militant
um shout out i want to say two man shout
out to a sacramento legend who just
passed dj geo
r.i.p to him man
fella if you let me tell it one of them
real ones
uh big dog man
i'm saying i ain't really understand
what he meant
to the whole city of sacramento i
understood what he meant to me but i
ain't understand what he meant to the
city of sacramento i mean you got the
people from the other side posting them
you know i'm saying you got you know
people who shouldn't be posting him
posting just due to the politics due to
the political affairs right people who
shouldn't be posting and posting
and uh
he was he
he was different he was different tweaky
full of confidence he was one of the
most
most confident individuals that i came
across
uh last conversation with him every
conversation with him was a flex he
flexing and uh
a loving forward i love him for it
yeah rest in peace man for sure um
how close were you because i feel like
when you were doing like when you were
you ended up on the black panther
soundtrack obviously you got embraced by
tde was there ever any sort of
conversations about maybe going over to
td and [ __ ] with top
uh not between not between us and them
more more so like just between us like
that'd be a good look for us that'd be a
good fit i think that'd be dope but um
nothing like i'm seeing me
who who was it that reached out was it
kendrick they reached out to you guys or
who was it
yeah kendrick he functioned with us just
the whole camp over there you know what
i'm saying they invited us to a studio
session the whole camp school boy
um just the whole camp j rock
uh top the whole family that's you know
they that's damn they're biologically by
a lot we damn they're biologically
related
yeah and then obviously uh you and yg
threw out a a great project last year
just something to feed the streets real
quick jizzle yeah now you know that's my
dog for sure
um
we locked in and naturally came down
wasn't enforced
i feel like you um i feel like
you sharpened his sword a lot
vice versa too vice versa two and i say
that cause uh
you know he he i feel like he he got
more
more established for sure industry-wise
yeah i'm saying and uh that's what i'm
looking for that's what i was looking
for the whole the whole he you know he
like bro we got to get on some gangster
[ __ ] i'm like nah [ __ ] we need to get
off
that [ __ ]
i've been making music with this guy
blast for a long time and right now be a
good time together
so we i mean but uh good vibes he going
there he does dougie just the way he
recorded his whole recording process you
know i i grab a notebook i get the
scribbling he jumped right in there and
he just let it ooze out naturally um
but nah that's my dog for sure i
function with that project too make sure
you all tweak on that uh and then you
and blast have had such a dope
relationship before before blast was
like blast huh you know what i'm saying
like he was still black he was still
blast but this is yeah this was before
the plaques i suppose right
he was kind of like la's best kept
secret um but yeah you guys have had
such a crazy you know y'all's records
are so crazy the dynamic is crazy i
smelt it on him out the gates his his
talent was undeniable
uh i love telling this story but
it's our people probably tired of
hearing this [ __ ] but um
you know he was he was supposed to be
writing he was writing for somebody i
mean he was he wrote a hook and i was
supposed to have somebody else redo the
and whole i'm like [ __ ] that they were
we need to keep him i ain't even know
him i'm like whoever him is keep him on
it he's him he's one of them guys like
he he just dope i couldn't see nobody
else like tweaking it like he tweaked it
like they could probably i'm saying try
to fill it in but i couldn't imagine
them like
the way he did it is done and uh we kept
him and you know it was like i said he
was him he did his dougie and uh very
respectable like is he gonna be on the
new album everything he dropped is just
you hear me
ah girl you're chosen
ah that's my [ __ ] right now shout out
blast he's most definitely on the new
album he's damn they're gonna be on
every album we dropped from now on uh
it's only right now it's only right i'll
function with him heavy you know what i
love that i love him out of his success
too must continue success
i love uh on this last burner album
burner put you what was that lineup of
that record it was like you conway
benny the butcher benny
uh was styles on there or something it
was it was a lot of it was it was real
rap
that was real rap burn when he sent that
to me and i'm saying and he was telling
me so i ain't gonna lie to me and burn
we had a you know a little brief
conversation about how a couple [ __ ]
sizzled me on that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know did you know who was gonna be
on it you know i'll just be getting
sizzled like that right right right
right right but uh nah he he most
definitely hit me to who was going who's
gonna be on it but i don't think i got
to hear these verses if i'd have got to
hear they versus i'd have blacked out
blacked out um i made an attempt but
after hearing they verses i was like oh
yeah
yeah he even called me too like bro i
think brett got you you know i ain't
gonna say no names uh yeah you you
that's actually one of my favorite
projects is the the slimy individual
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is crazy they too are
function with that burn another person
you know what i'm saying we just get it
he's a great a r too i feel like he'll
be putting people on records
how you know what how you know
that's his no that's his gift i i swear
i know bro you pinpointed that he i feel
like burn be putting people together
that like
[ __ ] he's one of the illest that i just
told that [ __ ] i need him to a and r my
whole project insanity beat selection uh
everything he just banged that cancer
yeah he just beat cancer so you know he
was really opposed to anr this whole
project fought me at least a couple
songs on that [ __ ] but uh dude
you know what i'm saying me his is is is
gangster [ __ ] he had going on uh
he missed this one but on the double
back i'm most definitely going to lock
in with him on my next project and hey
him do his dougie because like you said
just even with our project like them is
some of my favorite songs yeah like the
fact he put like you yg and logic on a
record
and that [ __ ] was hard as [ __ ] like who
would ever have thought like let me put
logic on the song with mazzy and yg you
know what i'm saying it came out insane
razor yeah fella
super crazy uh what you know obviously i
i just saw when you by the way that
[ __ ] interview did with t-rail and
a.d was great you smell it on me i love
those guys shout out to juno most
definitely oh yeah my boys i had to give
either give them i told a.d i'm like man
you got it bruh vibes that was good
vibes on my mama they was on my line
about them spandex pants though
they was tweaking on me like that kim
they was twigging on me i said i'm not
wearing no i'm not even [ __ ] around
with slim fit or none of that you hear
me you see i came in with my car goes
today you know what's crazy i'm not
gonna get me again without the slim the
slim fit was a thing and i feel like
it's going the other way again listen
i'm cargoed up for now on no more slim
fit i'm not [ __ ] around bobby brown
uh dogs gonna say you talked about like
you know taking the money from uh your
cmg situation reinvesting against some
apartments yeah for sure now you know i
got to keep that lit that side of the
field i got to keep that side of the
field lit that's one of the um the
avenues i want to travel down when i'm
done with rap just real estate
um
and i don't want to make it seem like
i'm just heavy in real estate like [ __ ]
just be buying houses selling flipping
houses and selling houses et cetera et
cetera yeah i'm saying me i'm more just
like taking the chicken that i get and
buying property sitting on it i'm saying
so the same way we would go oh a jeweler
50 000 and we you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] knock that out fast i'm saying 20
000 here 15 000 here 15 000 here it's
kind of same thing the same way i'm
operating with the property um same way
we do cars you know i'm seeing me [ __ ]
spend [ __ ] 250 000 wire transfer 200
[ __ ] wire quarter million for
automobile what kind wait what car did
you get that was 250. let's just you
know i want to know not a lamborghini
truck oh okay a lamborghini truck but uh
you know the same way we do that is
instead instead of that like you know i
just see i see uh the equity i see the
equity i just see the benefits with the
property
i'm saying may i check the uh what is it
the estimates the zest estimates on
zillow yeah
i'll be checking this testament oh my
shit's up at [ __ ] be 30k a month
yeah [ __ ] so it'd be like uh let alone
you know i'm saying the passive income
uh on top of that we get [ __ ] 30k in
equity a month and then uh we ain't even
gonna talk about you know the money that
we reinvested as far as fixing it up and
of course the rehab yeah but um i've
been i've been really enjoying that and
uh you know i've been really knocking
them down like as far as knocking the
mortgages down i've been banging them
out that's smart man because the way you
you got to everybody when you uh
instead of keeping your money in like a
checking account
just buy a house look at it like it's a
bank you can pull out any time you can
sell it at any time and it's going to go
up for sure now that somebody just told
me that i think i had like 300 000 cash
and they like what that don't make no
sense nobody even told me that i seen it
on instagram and they was just telling
they was you know just busting it down i
really don't make no sense and the us
dollars depreciating like a [ __ ]
because of inflation you might as well
go buy something that isn't depreciating
yes yeah that's appreciating and so uh
that's what i've been on um your lambo
trucks probably worth more than you
bought bought it for now i think it is
because of the uh car shortage yeah
somebody even been trying they've been
trying to cash me out but uh take the
money man go buy another apartment
complex that's what i should do hell
yeah what you need a lambo truck for bro
you're mozzie kid what i'ma drive in man
you got something for me you gonna loan
me something you got a loaner for me
just get an escalade bruh get like
something you know that's i'm too big
well get a [ __ ] uh get out get out of
here get something chill you're mozzie
bro we know you got it
this guy's posted his distribution
statements on the internet we know what
kind of money he's coming there can't
live without it ain't not for sure now
uh i ain't gonna lop in and the buick's
heavy too i've been buying little
scrapers i love my shout out to the
buicks what year are we talking here i'm
talking about 80 what's that eight what
was it 93s 94s
buick centuries
uh of course i'm i'm in love with i
think the 96
rivieras
rivieras uh park avenue what got you in
the buicks that's what i was that's what
we was into when i was a youngin okay so
you know 17 18 that that was i'm seeing
me that was the culture where i'm from
so that was that's the culture when i
was a kid the buick was like the car
that like the trap car we could afford
it was like we get that buick le saber
you know what i'm saying
but you put the laser on foes or you
thought it yeah i'm saying you cut it up
throw the sixes on the laser put some
can some type of candy on there yeah i
mean it throw the slit nap in there
there you have it that's him
is buick still uh active like they
dropping new cars oh no we don't you
know i ain't up on a any if they drop a
new car we're uninterested
you should get a tesla bro that's what
you should get a tesla yeah get a tessie
man i'm kind of ugly though
yeah they also got the electric cars
though they got that the new uh i mean
just imagine you gotta go take your car
and they're gonna go charge it up
that's right come on ain't got time to
be charged no cars that's real it's like
a [ __ ] iphone yeah
my [ __ ] gonna be on low battery all day
bro i just had somebody i know uh my
wife's friend called my wife in a panic
my our kids go to the same school
and she was like i forgot to charge the
car last night so i can't pick up my son
can you pick him up
damn imagine waking up thinking about to
go to work
and you forgot to plug it in
it's slimy yeah uh i'll probably go get
me like a little audi truck or something
a little oddie truck it flipped the
lambo truck yeah now you're right let's
get another one when the chips short
because right now there's a car shortage
not ain't lambos ain't even in no more
the lambo truck ain't even in everybody
got them you're probably right i'm gonna
go i'm gonna go do that you wanna buy my
[ __ ] not at all
i like my cars to be fully paid off and
uh yeah i just bought a house in burbank
so i'm [ __ ] poorest oh you're on your
[ __ ] that's what i just yeah bro that's
my last interview i said i went broke i
went broke a property that's that's the
name of it but it's a it's a good it's a
good
they call it house pour you'd rather be
house poor
than poor poor you know what i'm saying
sure because you could take out money
out of your crib at any time for sure
and you get that residual bread coming
in like you said how many uh units is
your apartments four units so four plex
four flicks nice yeah [ __ ] run it up man
is it
back home nah it's right here in your
jurisdiction oh then you're getting
great money airbnb
but you know airbnb they kind of slimy
right now they doing a
what is that called uh
rent control
where it'd be like yeah i'm saying hey
hey kind of kind you ain't hey i ain't
gonna let you make 15 20 000 a month off
of it they got it you got to go off with
every everybody else right which is
trash but yeah but it's still it's still
legitimate i still function with it it's
still very beneficial my boy's got like
10 cars
and he puts them all on the turo app
have you heard of turo most definitely
and he's making [ __ ] bank no he ain't
he's killing it
what kind of car has he got he's got a
i8 uh jeep rubicon he putting the dope
[ __ ] on there yeah but he's also got
like
you know like a kia telluride
but he's got like all like nine of them
are rented out at a time and then he
drives one i've been hearing about that
game it's a it's it's kind of a it's
it's one way to like because most times
you think about buying that [ __ ] they
both [ __ ] around with that [ __ ] right
now davo you you ran your car out
he but you know he just started so we
we're gonna we're gonna holla at that
[ __ ] in about two months and we're
gonna see how beneficial once you get
those reviews up is when they start
coming in more that's when they function
that's what my boy did yeah my boy is
killing it now yeah because he has a car
problem now look we i got i got bro was
just talking about that because i'm like
you go you go get a house bam you spend
quarter million on a house something
like right of course i'm not talking out
of your pocket uh yeah out of your
pocket all right bam
you get your rent you still got to pay
mortgage so uh
you rent it out you probably profit off
a mortgage after they pay the mortgage
in on top of the you probably profit
like 1500 or something all right that's
1500 monthly outside of the equity
coming in but if you go spend that same
quarter on vehicles
you know what i'm saying it's the same
quarter on vehicles
put it on touro
i think you can make like
seven eight thousand and i mean there's
no equity
no equity but that's what i'm saying if
you if you're tripping off the equity
the nsu should go to house route but if
you ain't tripping off the equity then i
think the cars i think the cars is more
beneficial as far as like
on-demand paper
yeah as far as
money it's easily accessible monthly
residual brand yeah come on that's real
yeah that makes sense yeah that makes
sense because because if you're making
if your car is being rented out 25 days
a month or 20 days a month
you're making more money because your
your payment's lower yeah you can make
more money off of one vehicle
so if you go get five six vehicle you
can make more money off one vehicle than
what you're making off a house every
month but uh so we're gonna be able to
rent his lamborghini truck off toronto
very soon it'll be on davos account
though yeah for sure most definitely
mandatory snatch make sure y'all tweak
on my [ __ ] we got to stop the interview
real quick man shout out to our sponsors
at blue chew the good thing about blue
chew not only does it make that dick
[ __ ]
you know what i mean get that thing
swinging like it never swung before
but what i love about blue chew is
it's all online man you know usually
when you want to go and get some of that
uh you know some of that good good some
of that blue juice maybe some viagra
first of all it's got the same exact
active ingredients as viagra and as
cialis but you don't have to go into the
doctor's office to get it all right all
you got to do is go to bluetooth.com you
have an online consultation and then
they discreetly
send it to you and it's also discreet
villain you know what i'm saying
it's crazy let me tell you something
maybe you got a first date you want to
make sure you blow them back out that
thing you know what i'm saying
whoa
pop that blue chew it's a chewable form
some people don't like swallowing pills
ladies are going to love to swallow you
though once you're on that blue chew
i'll tell you that much bud for sure so
what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg and you're
going to get a month supply of blue chew
for free all right you're gonna thank me
later for this uh what other uh [ __ ] are
you getting into man just like in in
terms of just you know investing or
you know
uh that's all i've been really tweaking
on as far as investing is that um
i try to stay focused on this music as
much as i can try to get my run in so as
far as like you know just
just dropping albums to merch
um these shows
um are you cause you what i'd be doing
is i'd be like i how am i able to even
invest in a property through the music
the music is what's going on that's what
feeds everything so like
like get on your [ __ ] [ __ ] that's why i
tell everybody who's independent if
you're not assigned
you're crazy if you're only dropping
music all the [ __ ] time well get on
your [ __ ] people do you think people
you like see other artists overthinking
[ __ ] that are independent and like
because i always know not about people
definitely people have been sitting on
music for too long i'm just gonna say
that i know [ __ ] who will create a
whole album and won't drop that
[ __ ] like you said they
overthinking um
and you know just a lot of
procrastinating they feel like it's
gonna be it gotta be perfect right and
then by the time they they moved on to
some notion the other [ __ ] is old and
yeah it's like bro you could have gotten
money off that that's part of your
catalog for sure but not so i just try
to uh i try to focus on what's
generating chicken right now like i love
to i love to just fall back and just
tweak on real estate 100 percent i love
to do that but uh it's it's not what's
generating my paper as we speak
i'm seeing me and so i'm able to even
tweak on real estate do the rap and so
it'd be like all right let me focus let
me zero in on this [ __ ] and uh basically
ring it out for everything it's worth um
are you able to like like right now
obviously now that we're finally past
the pandemic
i know you're able to you know get get
to get the show money together most
definitely
is it is it like for you like um
because you know sometimes i'll see an
artist from like
i don't know the south right and you
know in the south or midwest they're
getting a stupid bag and then they'll
come out here to the west coast you know
specifically i'm talking about arizona
because i always book people in arizona
and they're they're trying to get the
same bag in arizona that they might get
in like you know people don't understand
that game you gotta understand that i
was just telling somebody about that
like uh
you know out here i'm able to charge
35 right so get it
sell out no problem but it'd be like i
jump i jump a couple states
and uh you know they get spicy you know
i'm saying the offers it trickled down
to 20 15 and it'd be like but i'ma eat
that up but i'm gonna eat that up not
not not for the not specifically for the
paper i'm gonna do that for that fan
base you want to spread you want to
spread your [ __ ] out man most definitely
so it'd be like even if it's that
long-term thinking yeah if i got to go
on a run and do 10 shows for i'm saying
15 000 on that side of the field even
though i'm getting 35 on this side of
the field i'ma still run that concurrent
i'm gonna run that concurrent and not
for the 15 000. i ain't really doing it
for the paper i'm doing it yeah i'm
saying so i could beat that [ __ ]
up they could become well aware and very
familiar with the fella and then after
that they gonna respect my gangster when
i double back and tell them i need
thirty five and i'm saying and so you
know it's all a part of the game and one
once upon a time i was doing shows for
2500 it jumped to 5 000. bro i've seen
it with my own eyes come on it's the
name of the game so it'd be like even
the verses i don't even know i don't
even know your verse has got to be a
pretty penny these days same thing so
it's just it's just it's rap hustle i
respect the hustle so uh you know i
don't really complain you ain't gonna
hear me on the internet complaining too
much nor a person i ain't gonna complain
too much um i'm really just uh grateful
i'm grateful to even be in this position
you know i'm seeing me and uh you know
to be able to
reap the benefits off of something that
i do for free feel me um have you are
you still like pretty active when it
comes to just selling versus like
because you know sometimes that can work
against you because maybe you water down
your brand a little bit nah most
definitely but when you're independent i
feel like you know it it it puts keeps
the lights on sometimes for sure um
i enjoy it all so now i ain't really i
ain't turning down nothing i ain't
turning down nothing there's never been
a song that's coming that's been so
terrible that you're like nah nah they
be coming
trash [ __ ]
like do not put me on primary artists on
this [ __ ] not you hear me
looking [ __ ] crazy hey but now they
come with anything they come with the
bag they come with the baggage claim and
uh so i'm most definitely jumping on it
get me right yeah i'm saying the song's
terrible
you'll be like i need a little more the
song is trash and they got more they got
everything they got the whole bag they
got what i asked for
i'ma knock it out
business business what about the video
business is business bro
i ain't gonna lie business is business
you got everything i don't go [ __ ] i
post post that [ __ ] on my story
one time going about my business have
you done any ghost writing
not yet
not yet what about just helping like uh
you know i feel like um nah i don't
nobody want my assistance you don't
think you don't think so i feel like
i've seen your reputation go from like
mozzie he's a problem
you know he's a hectic guy
to i feel like everyone [ __ ] loves
you now nah they function with me but
they don't want my assistance and uh i
ain't been lending out my assistance um
i ain't i ain't really trying to
scribble for nobody not [ __ ] not i ain't
i think i do that when it's all said and
done jake paul comes to you he's like yo
i need you to write me a song you gotta
you gotta do that right
no they i ain't gonna lie somebody they
as far as movies is concerned
they didn't hit me i said they need me
to write some write some [ __ ] recite it
you know i'm standing in somebody else's
they they'll take it and you know
they'll redo it so uh in that manner but
as far as like i ain't really been i
ain't i ain't been soliciting in that
field um but if jake paul got his
chicken he got his mcnuggets right he's
got him no i know he do what if he gave
you a psa 10 pokemon like pikachu card
and you had to write like three songs
i don't know nothing about pikachu so i
gotta come out at you
oh they got did you see he got ripped
off yeah jake paul he or no his brother
logan paul say logan problem
no listen logan paul spent a million
dollars on pokemon cards and they were
all fake all of them
it was a fake flipped on him
i said whoever hit that lit god bless
him and he bought it with crypto man so
that [ __ ] is gone you can't get the
crypto back [ __ ]
mama called boo lay care gangland what
you doing check it out this [ __ ]
offered me some pokemon cards i know
nothing about i need you to come don't
call me my producer nico blitz he'll
tell you he got pokemon tattoos
i just know that they're expensive brad
but you know charizard used to be lit
back in the day you never [ __ ] with
pokemon when you're a kid i ain't i
wouldn't nah
i ain't i was sleeping on poker because
i feel like we're similar in age so now
we we most definitely is but i
what about pogs do you remember paw
patrol yeah that's the slammers yeah
damn quit playing i was in school
[ __ ] around bobby brown we used to
steal pokemon cards but i never knew
where to take them you know what's funny
is i used to do the same i never was
into pokemon cards but i used to steal
them from other kids at school yeah
and then sell them come on back to them
like in like a month i'd be like oh yeah
you wanna yeah i never actually played
pokemon cards but i was you know hip to
like
which ones were hot but pogs were a
movie not a holographics
the holographics here then was the worms
quit playing
i wasn't stealing nothing that wasn't
holographic were you uh were you into
wrestling back then
uh they had it because because the
attitude era was lit during the during
this era of time man new world order man
nwo man quit playing yeah i'm saying
rest in peace
my [ __ ] rest in peace that [ __ ] what
was his name brett hart brother owen
heart owen heart blood that was my [ __ ]
kane when that [ __ ] came undertaker i
was really [ __ ] with undertaker heavy
and then when you found out he had a
brother man that [ __ ] kane
oh it was game over bro the rollout of
kane as undertaker's brother mysterio
junior you all know that about ray
mysterio that was the flashiest [ __ ] on
like he [ __ ] the realm who else who
else would oh my [ __ ] uh that [ __ ] who
used to stick his his paws and [ __ ]
mankind mankind
dirty socks
mr sacco mr
sacko
now yeah i used to [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
heavy oh my mama's hey ray mysterio just
wrestled at wrestlemania he just he just
wrestled logan paul yeah he bet yeah him
and his son wrestled logan paul that's
my [ __ ] i [ __ ] with ray hey shout out
to rey mysterio for sure huh
he's i looked it up thinking what you're
thinking like god he got to be i think
he's like 51 i'm like damn he because he
was lit when he was like a kid bro he
was like 18 19
when we were watching him
oh you're here because it's crazy
because like he would still look good
he's still jumping and doing all that
flying [ __ ] all that six one nine [ __ ]
he tweeting like this how to look up his
age i said this [ __ ] ain't as
old as i remember
this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] yeah now
wrestling is still i'm still a grown man
who watches it so you know there's never
got out of it something i couldn't get
out i think nobody bigger than rick
flair though
i mean rick flair is arguably the
greatest of all time okay
and he had a nice little hip hop
resurgence with offset bad bunny was
showing him love nobody bigger than ric
flair
shout out the big show i [ __ ] with the
big show
the rock oh okay no i'm disrespecting
the rock you smell
what the [ __ ] rock is booking
but look though
stone cone steve austin he's the ghost
in my opinion that's the ghost in black
come on yeah stone cold he just wrestled
too that's my [ __ ] shout out to stone
cold remember when everybody hated him i
remember when everyone had the [ __ ]
t-shirts bro everybody hated stone cone
i love everybody and then fell in love
with that [ __ ] overnight stone clothes
a legend
you got to get some of these we got to
get one of these guys to do a skit on
your album probably stone cold stone
cold skit boy what or just like talking
[ __ ] on the outro of a record you
imagine you do the intro and then after
your verse stone cold just popping that
[ __ ] at the end you hear me
come on
[ __ ] rick hey rick flair will do it
for like five bands just
have ric flair just just get his [ __ ]
off bro
for sure [ __ ] dougie for sure oh shout
out to uh to uh stone cold man um
you know it's crazy man because i do
feel like
right now
is probably
a lot of people feel like streaming kind
of killed
the music industry but i feel like it's
the best time to be an artist
because
there's no excuse if you uh if you have
a [ __ ] computer
you could you could go buy an interface
from from guitar center you could buy a
200 might get it bro it's no excuse you
can get a two core account additional
kit account and upload it to the world
just like that i'm ecstatic about this
old [ __ ] i'm juice um
i remember it was a plain time where you
had to
you had to like press cds and put up
flyers and
this [ __ ] just made it the whole
internet just made it hella easier it's
at your fingertips and um
you know it's it like you said it's no
excuse you you ain't no excuses
uh
i'm saying me just
imagine when we have cds and they play
your album they can play 50
100 hours of your cd and you only get
that money once
you get that ten dollars that's it
nowadays the more they listen the more
money you get
so i love it i respect it i function
with it heavy and uh like you said it it
it give it's access for anybody to
become an artist anybody mm-hmm it's
just wide open
what would be something uh some advice
you would give like somebody who got a
little traction in their city but don't
really kind of you know
know what to do to like kind of break
through and like kind of because i feel
like you had a moment where i feel like
you really were
i guess
a california-like secret or a west coast
secret i think and i feel like you broke
through around the time the one up top
album came out i feel like that was kind
of your
breakthrough moment
uh what i say is the advice i give is uh
probably
i mean you know the best out of
everything i'd have done in my career
just moving around
moving around jumping on the freeways
and um i say that just you know cause uh
you're gonna be the most hated in your
city
just due to political reasons alone
whether i'm saying just political even
if you're not a politician even if you
ain't politicking right right right
through the political reasons they gonna
hate you but as soon as you i'm saying
skip a couple states or skip a couple
cities over it's like um
it's like
it's like you're a foreigner and i'm
seeing me you you they smell it on you
you're a little different and everybody
gravitate towards that so uh the same
way i was a sacramento [ __ ] i migrated
to the bay bay area fell in love with it
by the way people who aren't like real
fans of yours still thinking from the
beginning
some people yo you know the bass lit
mines i'm like mazzy is from southern
man oh my oh my
hey they tried to bop but just
everything
stocked in sacramento everything is
debate like you don't it's not that nah
nah valley love valley love shout out to
the yay area but uh [ __ ] migrated to
the yay area they fell in love with a
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm saying jumped a couple
cities over [ __ ] ended up in l.a they
fell in love with a [ __ ] i'm not a
politician in la mcme um so it's easy
for the key ways to function with me
it's easy for the bloods to lock in with
me yeah i'm seeing me um [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] jump on a flight night and i'm
saying go [ __ ] with kansas city they
fall in love with a [ __ ] arizona it
just starts spreading but i think the
whole thing is um you know uh just just
spreading your wings man getting outside
of your your circumference getting
outside of your comfort zone and uh to
the point where it'd be like this [ __ ]
gotta work if you at home you got
options and you and you stop rapping and
go get a job it's that comfort it's that
confidence you get out i tell everybody
move out of your [ __ ] hometown
cause then it's gotta you gotta make it
work
because there's no not options you can't
go to your mom's house that's not
optional yeah ain't no comfort zone
you've got to so uh that's my whole
thing is just jumping on that freeway
man putting miles putting miles on that
automobile that's the illest man i tell
that [ __ ] to people all the time i i
talk to so many people
you know i got homies of mine who i've
been trying to get to leave their
hometown specifically phoenix arizona uh
like yo man get the [ __ ] out of there
like that's your house yeah like yo i
ain't know phoenix was your house i was
trying to figure out why you were
celebrating your birthday in phoenix
arizona cause i'm from there i ain't no
i was asleep okay you just woke my game
up but it's like got all the baddest
[ __ ] you're right i give it to you
you're right
no lie huh hey my wife's from phoenix so
yes you're right i married one of them
yo we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our partners at
odd socks watch this i bet you i got out
socks on right [ __ ] now
oh yeah see them bad boys these are what
we call the odd socks basics the ankles
the ankle socks all right go to
oddssocksofficial.com right now
put the website up promo codes bootleg
cab you're going to save 20 off at
checkout they got so many crazy ass
socks we got twizzlers [ __ ] halloween
uh
i mean these are kind of satanic it just
says demon
they were like let's just do a generic
demon sock
i mean this is kind of like uh
i guess like if you were in the 80s in
miami doing cocaine off of a stripper's
[ __ ]
jaws pepsi i mean listen breaking bad
nickelodeon keep going but what's most
important is odd socks is our family
look if you support odd socks you
support the bootleghead podcast so go to
bootleg kev well you can go to
bootleghead.com and just check it out
but you could also go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev and save
20 off at checkout do that [ __ ] right
now all right let's get into the uh
interview that we've already been inside
of but we're going to get back to it
right now az's different you know what's
crazy is i saw you do uh
you had your tour and you did a press
room like three years ago i hosted the
show
that's uh stupid young showed up hella
late and hopped on and just did mando
you remember that he missed his whole
performance
but it was maybe half full
it wasn't like it wasn't sold out it
wasn't close to sold out it looked good
but it was but then you just did the
stratus event center like i don't know
last year when was that that was like
eight nine months ago
it's just like 2 500 sold out bro and it
sold out like way way in advance like
bro i think on tour phoenix was the
first one to sell out
and then they canceled us that was
phoenix or was it portland
washington seattle oh that was seattle
okay but now every time we go to phoenix
it's against the party that [ __ ]
be lit they didn't show so much love um
i love a-z it's a good place man i love
a-z and the property down here is
legitimate so i've been thinking about
yeah
let's go let's buy an apartment complex
mazzy me and you yeah
come on let's get to it let's get us a
fourplex out there get to it come on
we'll just keep one open for when you're
in town most definitely the airbnb the
rest of the [ __ ] running
control no there isn't [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
there is no rent control it is a
conservative state they don't and you
can move around az strap the [ __ ] up
legitimate zero uh gun laws like
legitimate like i could just give you a
gun
i'd be like hey this this was my dad's
here you go you could have it i don't
gotta go register that [ __ ] and
then nope put that [ __ ] in your pocket
get it pulled over you're fine
it's a that's my gun now it's mine you
don't gotta register bro you can move
it's crazy as long as you ain't kill
nobody with that gun and they looking
for those serial numbers you straight
it's a good place good place and we're
going to win the nba title this year
[ __ ] the warriors you think you got it
of course
he said [ __ ] the warriors why i'm saying
well i'm from sacramento [ __ ] bro why
about to say you're a king's fed
boogie ain't been there in a while
you got darren fox now all right dear
dear you saw deer in fire i'm far back
on that one yeah yeah yeah well you saw
deer in fox scout he got tied up with
some nft [ __ ] they're trying to take his
ass to easy
going through it yeah man i'm gonna be
[ __ ] with the nfts
i don't understand the space enough
i do crypto so i [ __ ] with bitcoin and
like crypto certain coins the nft [ __ ] i
feel like is wide open for a lot of
fraud right and it is a lot of people
are getting
hit [ __ ] nba player soldier boy uh who
else would oh tory lanez got hit with
some [ __ ]
uh you just gotta be careful man we
don't [ __ ] around because it feels like
a anything that feels like a get money
quick situation man
if if it's too good to be true
ppp money
come on i know three people who just got
indicted you're lying i'm like bruh they
ain't gonna get everybody what they
giving [ __ ] for that
uh
one
one of my boys they just
seized his in his all his assets he's
broke like this dude was like well off
but they ain't giving no time it's kate
he's he's got to go to court
but yeah man they ain't gonna get
everybody but it's starting to come
around that ppp shit's starting to
bounce back i ain't play with it you
better show [ __ ] where their
employees went
all them w-9s i was scared of that
movement
yeah me too and i thought about it too
because i just opened the studio and all
my homies were scammers they're like hey
man you got a business you got an llc
you could get like 50.
i'm not jeopardizing mine i'm like you
know what i'm gonna be honest with you
[ __ ] was coming back with treasure
trunks full of that [ __ ] lambo trucks
yeah speaking of lambo trucks i said
everybody got a lamborghini truck
man
shout out to the dude pretty ricky
dude's in prison right now he's doing
time i think he's doing serious time
what do you do 18 months or something
is that what he doing
is it 18 that's not bad but still
jake i go to prison for 18 months for 5
million dollars
yeah he's like what are we talking about
here it's it's federal prison too it's
probably federer the feds are supposed
to be the nicest like
is that true oh no prison is prison you
ask me
prison is prison i mean you know
especially when you when you're out here
winning
now if you just broke and you were
bummed and i feel like yeah yeah i mean
that then dennis you could say the
nicest prison and all that [ __ ] but when
you're living when you living when you
really live in a
prison is prison i don't give a [ __ ] who
what when where and why i've only been
to jail twice and each time i ended up
having to use toilet paper as a pillow
every time every time to get the pill
the toilet paper roll oh yeah now that's
that that's the you you start off with
that in the hole yes you start off with
that now i mean not the whole uh the
holding cell the whole cell yeah
yeah i mean but then by by that time
when you get to your bunk [ __ ] you
should be plush i should know bouley
[ __ ] in this [ __ ] man get that
[ __ ] right man two blankets here go a
fresh pair of drinks you know what's
funny is that me i went to jail for the
night like semi recently and uh
they ain't seen you know i care that
supposed to be slipping [ __ ] underneath
the door three people three like three
people literally the guy who's across
from my holding cell was like
what the [ __ ] are you doing here i'm
like [ __ ]
i'm like is this a good thing or bad i
don't know it's a good thing bro i mean
you win this [ __ ] so off the
dribble that [ __ ] finish send you to a
couple noodles and [ __ ] because he know
you got baggage claim coming [ __ ] in a
week or so yeah i'm saying he know [ __ ]
your chicken is up the park you got
phone time so he already yeah i'm saying
he putting it together on your ass
are you um are you good at making that
[ __ ] have full suits in there he gonna
get you three yes
how's your spread making skills i still
spread to this day g.o.d my daughters
don't [ __ ] with it but [ __ ] i still
spread to this day what's like what's in
your see mine like i'm a gourmet spread
[ __ ] i ain't no real jailhouse [ __ ] to
the point where i could bust down the
sweet and sour or you know what i'm
saying chicken chow mein and you know
[ __ ] fries shrimp fried rice like
[ __ ] [ __ ] know how to wet burritos
tamales [ __ ] know how to really bust
that [ __ ] down in there i'm just a uh
i'm a butt naked type [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying so you know you just you
get the you boil the noodles boom i mean
throw the cheese in there hot the hot
sauce
you crush up all the chips spread that
on top of that
put a couple jalaenos in there ah grab
you a little tortilla
throw that over there real quick you got
you a little spring there yeah actually
sounds like diarrhea nice candy lick you
not hearing me i
do this every day you're still eating
that every day
every like whenever i'm seeing me my
significant she pump faking she acting
like she ain't she don't want to make
dinner you're like don't worry i got
this i got it i can handle this myself
she pumped faking on lunch oh no problem
yeah i'm saying so yeah we got to get
you an air fryer mozzie
i got one i don't know how to utilize it
so you put anything in it and just hit
start and it's it's anything you could
put a raw chicken breast in that [ __ ]
you know i told you [ __ ] i'm i'm bougie
nowadays so what's they call that but
you're eating spread every day not that
bouchy ain't that bougie but what's that
[ __ ] they call uh uh uh
not grubhub oh postmates
postmates oh you just post meetings how
much i'm probably one of they i'm saying
i'm one of their clients all kinds of
bossa nova coming in huh
with cheesecake factory
um they be taxing too they do be taxing
but it's smooth though cause it's like
you ain't gotta go you ain't gotta go
but there's the risk that it comes and
it's [ __ ] cold or it's all [ __ ] up
and i had somebody nah but it's cool
because it's coming to your house so say
if you order a rib eye and that
[ __ ]
and you want that [ __ ] extra
throw it on the grill yeah
you just re-rock it it's my feet
now i imagine if you see imagine if you
order it and you're on the road and then
you know i'm saying you pick that
[ __ ] up and then you all jump on
the freeway and then you're not gonna
drive back home no drive back yeah you
can't do nothing with it [ __ ] just
can't eat it you know what i'm saying
but whatever that that when they come
when they land at the house on the front
porch i don't even open the door for
them i let them drop it off drop brush i
don't even want to see you yeah yeah
uh what is uh what is in your rotation
tv show wise what are you watching man
oh
of course we watching uh what is that
snowfall this season has been a little
disappointing right oh
almost over it's one more episode right
i think it's the worst season right you
just see the [ __ ] off the uh
off the drugs when they put the [ __ ] in
the chocolate i didn't see it oh yeah
where they were all tripping out
at the wedding lit huh
what the [ __ ] is they on was that that
[ __ ] you just gave me no that they were
on them
they were on lsd they were on lsd oh
okay let me see that pack no that's
psilocybin all right that ain't the same
thing no that's shrooms if y'all want to
feel like blood and then was feeling
blood
yeah i'm saying
if y'all want to feel like blood and
then was feeling blood make sure you get
these tops man
hey but not uh i love snowfall though
not eight that's i ain't gonna lie
that's my favorite episode uh of course
i've been waiting for uh bmf and them to
double back on me
um
power yeah i'm saying
uh what else the first 48s i'm on all
first 48s i'm tired of force freddie
they they got me running the old
episodes back you know what i'm saying
me because i don't watch all the new
keys
uh what else i'm on in there
you know uh oh kardashian just dropped
i'm saying ah
grip
i haven't watched it i'm just dapping
you because you're reaching out
did you watch the first episode on hulu
hey that's [ __ ] up how she did scott
you see how she did i didn't see it but
she got a new [ __ ] she ain't cool
and scott was the best part of the old
show was my [ __ ]
she just switched up on my [ __ ] skype
man i'm feeling some type of way
courtney g.o.d
hey this man scott on the show
he said
kim was like i wish i had uh sometimes i
wish i had a smaller butt and scott
disick told her
if you had a smaller butt none of this
money would be here
shout out to scott disney he's a savage
fellow i'll
keeping up with the kardashians guy you
know it's i mean i'm saying i would
blame it on her
but no i [ __ ] with the kardashians man
i don't like the way they doing my [ __ ]
either you know i'm saying uh you know
that i feel some type of way about kanye
yeah man that ain't bully boo blood
you feel me so kim me and kim we got the
holla i feel like kanye
like his they took him off ig and then
he just never came back like i don't
know what's that is what happened i
don't like how they're trying to make
because i i've been saying this like yo
man you can't tell anybody who's got
kids how to
react about their children or how to
like uh not but as big as he is you know
as big as he is you know what i'm saying
me that [ __ ] he got enough power enough
influence you know i'm saying to tweak
society so you know i kind of get it i
kind of i mean we got to respect that
big
he one of them fellas but on on the type
of time you want most definitely you
can't tell the [ __ ] nothing about his
young
enough
but uh you know i i think uh i think i
think that [ __ ] damn they're bigger
than that platform okay stripping
do you have how many kids you got marzie
i got two two girly faces
same same bm nah most definitely not uh
have you had a situation like uh that
kanye's going through where there's a
new boyfriend around like pete davidson
like skeet you know
i i ain't never indulged into that [ __ ]
so you've never had a situation where
one of your baby mama's look where the
first one she tried to play like that
[ __ ] that's why i got custody oh okay
okay yeah we're only on play them do you
have custody of both your kids i got
custody of one half custody other so you
know i'm one and a half one and a half
hey that's good most [ __ ] are
zero
hey but uh most definitely i think you
know my first one she tampered with me
on that type of time i wasn't feeling it
very uncomfortable feeling and uh so i i
took the you know i went i went the
proper route and did what i and did my
dougie i did what i was supposed to do
that's what i feel like that's what you
should do just like man just get i mean
but he [ __ ] with he ain't [ __ ]
with just kim he's funking with the
kardashians yeah that chris she's a
beast
chris is a [ __ ] killer boy
for sure kris jenner man i think it
feels funky with just kim here win but
chris
hey hey that one dude [ __ ] up the bag
what's his name chris's [ __ ]
that she was dating him forever
not her
talking about the what's her name
nah what's the dude's name that was
[ __ ] kim's mom forever the boyfriend
what's the dude's name
kim kardashian's mom's boyfriend
and kanye aired him out
and like called like man he dropped up
but how do you [ __ ] up
the kris jenner i know you're talking
about but i don't know
yeah the black dude corey corey corey
oh my boy he got caught shooting
oh you [ __ ] it up yeah
no
he [ __ ] it up yeah i didn't tell him
oh no it had leaked that he cheated
on paperwork you ain't gonna oh no no no
no cuz you said kanye on papers no no no
first of all he on black and white blood
it leaked that he cheated there was like
pictures and then like the next day
kanye threw up something and like [ __ ]
[ __ ] i was posting that [ __ ] too she he
was [ __ ] with her
she was [ __ ] with him oh my god mama
now you know we fumbled a bag every once
in a while man after we didn't ran it up
yeah i feel like you could end up with a
kardashian one day i just might i got
the ism
i mean this [ __ ] is in me man i mean it
ain't on me you know i'm gonna tell her
q-tip years and listen here yeah i mean
you ju
follow me like a one-way street yeah
sammy i'm just sitting i'm playing
mozzie is the only rapper besides e40
that talks the way he talks it's you
just it's just game non-stop it's like
you you got it it's it's it's really
northern cali it's that northern [ __ ]
for sure
hey by the way shout out to northern
cali um
yo we got to stop the interview real
quick tell us about uh i'm gonna tell
you about our partners in my bookie man
make sure you go to mybookie.ag right
now
is gambling season nba playoffs are
about to start what are we doing you can
still get your futures in on the mvp
vote as well you can bet on everything
in my bookie man so look what you got to
do is go to mybookie.com right now just
go to my bookie use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account this is important when you sign
up for a new account use that promo code
bootleg and they will give you
a deposit match free money up to a
thousand dollars so if you sign up and
you put 200 bucks in they're gonna give
you another 200 to bet with
thousand they're gonna give you another
thousand a bet with let's go for the
suns all the way just throw all your
money on the phoenix suns
all right and then bet that the warriors
won't make it out of the first [ __ ]
round because jokic is gonna [ __ ]
pound them in their ass probably great
odds on that one
anyway mybookie.ag
mybookie just [ __ ] google the [ __ ] my
bookie use the promo code bootleg and
they will match your deposit free money
free money up to a thousand dollars just
in general i feel like hey you see how
they [ __ ] me up on the last episode
about my cup how that [ __ ] was
empty nah you didn't see it i mean i
watched it oh yeah that was on my line
you ain't got nothing i could put in
this [ __ ] down there getting
empty
what do you want to have the same
episode i don't have any i don't know
what you got in there i know you kicked
the cup but it's not all the way kicked
out
yeah shout out to kick in the cup too on
god i think i've probably been a couple
years sober now man this [ __ ] feel good
so what's in the cup then at this point
we got sprite in there no i was drinking
some uh
some pre-workout uh
i ain't no i don't i ain't that healthy
yet man i'm saying [ __ ] ain't that
healthy yet hey he take that pre-workout
that [ __ ] happens
itching
that [ __ ] is crack
pre-workout hey by the way shout out to
my guy dave's looking [ __ ] lovely
yeah that [ __ ] he lost the weight i
gained it got lucky
you drink pre-workout your arms start
itching bro like you're on [ __ ] like
he knows because he's a trainer hey
buddy turn you up though
yeah
you'll drink some pre-workout and just
be
let's get some [ __ ] done
what are we doing
hey hey the kids got homework i can help
with the homework what are we doing
what
uh
i gotta hang up how much of that [ __ ]
you gotta drink
a little bit bro
one scuba have you [ __ ] wired
so i've never done like uh hard drugs
i've never done coconut and nah you'd
have to do the line never no you ain't
never treated a lot i would tell you i
don't give a [ __ ] are you from that era
bro listen buddy never in my life my
whole family's dope fiends i've been
scared of drugs my whole life right you
from a z
trust me that's where that [ __ ] comes
and meth and all that yeah arizona's
like the meth capital fat and all that
anyway not fetty fetty
and az is crazy listen they smoke it out
there [ __ ] popping it and [ __ ] they
smoke confetti
they're like [ __ ] it we're just going to
let it ride
it's crazy if you know whatever you've
never talked to molly no eat peel i've
never
i've only smoked weed and done shrooms
never sir
never
i swear to god
bro when i tell you my family are drug
addicts in and out of prison my whole
life how you how you all right listen
how you avoid all that but tamper with
shrooms
i barely started saying shrooms like two
years ago all right well who puts you on
one of the homies joe rogan man joe
watching the joe rogan podcast all he
does is talk about how his life changed
mike tyson's podcast mike tyson started
doing psychedelics changed his life for
him yeah
mike tyson be smoking the toad though
what's that dmt
oh no nothing about it i'm asleep
so mike tyson slate what's that so mike
tyson his whole life changed when he
started smoking dmt
like you know how like tyson is like
real well measured now he's like really
like spiritually whole most definitely
um so dmt is
uh the chemical that your body
produces it's this what the [ __ ] is the
name of this gland
when you when you're born and when you
die your body produces a chemical called
dmt
there's a frog
that sweats natural dmt it's located in
arizona actually and in costa rica
and people will sweat the frog out
and then they'll freebase
the sweat
you do it with a crack pipe so it's real
crackhead-ish
[Laughter]
[ __ ] smoke is frog sweat so if you ever
hear if you ever hear mike tyson talking
about
no so if you ever hear mike tyson
talking about uh
smoking what you do like put a nug a wee
in there with the frog and just no
rather nugget weed on it nah you just
[ __ ] it like dries up and it gets
hard
and then you [ __ ] smoke it
that's crazy right dm no it's dmt it's
supposed to be it's supposed to be
amazing i'm going to try it one day all
right but you've been tweaking on the
podcast and you like let me [ __ ] around
with some shrooms and you tampered with
them and that [ __ ] was just enlightened
yeah
yeah for sure
yeah no i never did call side effects no
i mean i mean you can have it depends on
how much you eat you might have a
interesting night but outside of that
you can wake up the next day and be all
right
but
[ __ ] i don't know you know when i was a
kid i found crack in my dad's drawer
that was rough it was around the same it
was around the exact same time i was
listening to ghetto dope by master p and
i was like [ __ ]
this that ghetto this the [ __ ]
masterpiece
me
and my best friend ramses
found that [ __ ] and we're like shout out
to master p every time [ __ ] ask me my
favorite rappers i never mentioned blood
but on the beat that was one of the
first [ __ ] bro that i really me too no
limit bro straight up i had to fake no
limit chain straight up i had all them
all the knowledge i had the fake no
limits
i could never afford no limit clothing
it was always too expensive you watched
all this movies man bowed about it
he played in the nba
dope's one of my [ __ ] most important
albums of my life that orange [ __ ]
case remember it was orange it was like
all the cases were plastic and colorful
it's like the shocker mama i went to the
movie theater to see how i got the hook
up i got the hookup was so fire crazy so
good people don't talk about that [ __ ]
that was a good ass movie
yeah he was a man masterpiece a [ __ ]
legend sure him uh and then who was a
man i remember when i was a kid i used
to [ __ ] jerk off to that girl
mercedes album cover she had an album
called rear end
she was bent over on that [ __ ]
you remember that album
that [ __ ] said mercedes
you remember the no the chick on no
limit i remember the chick on no limit
hold on no not me and x not me
x that's what i was thinking of mia x
now i gotta show you because you're
gonna see that x is kind of chubby yeah
she wasn't the one to jerk to for sure
unless you into the bb dubs you know
what i mean
mia x looks like she'll whip up some
fire fire ass food though
uh rear crazy and no limit you're gonna
remember this album cover because
mercedes
oh this [ __ ] was
ben oh and then like the ad would change
like depending on how many albums you
would
you know they used to choose oh i
remember mercedes you remember that
album artwork mama i never listened yeah
[ __ ] though that no one did oh you was
getting off to that
i don't remember
at least two
oh look at her she look she don't she
don't blew up on this is she is she mia
x looking now look right here
oh is that her
oh she no that can't be her there's no
way this is her velvet no this says rear
end like mercedes from no limit records
this is not oh that ain't her oh god i
got to be 50 now huh oh yeah this is
yeah she's got to be oh
now you know who i liked i like to want
uh silk the shocker was [ __ ] with
what's her name me um uh maya maya what
i love my yo maya she still i think
she's still legitimate today she is she
is i just i i did a club with her not
too long
of the new power ago
listen i don't know because i've never
watched power
he hate that [ __ ] said he don't watch
power i just haven't watched it hey man
i gotta i gotta listen bro that [ __ ]
look like tommy
i gotta watch it because now my boy
freddie's in the [ __ ] show so i gotta
watch it oh yeah
uh oh that was her though
maya i i paid no attention
i feel like maya was like one of the og
like man if that [ __ ] was like lit
right now like how she like if there was
only fans in like 99
she'd had the whole ruby road [ __ ] going
up
holy fans in 99 can you imagine if there
was only fans in 99 all the ill [ __ ] we
would have saw
we had to [ __ ] steal vhs tapes
do you remember watching porn on video
oh my mama on a vcr on a vcr bra
on a vcr
ain't nothing like watching porn like
that way because then you gotta really
sit through it or you gotta fast forward
and it's not as easy to fast forward now
you gotta fast forward it'd be a 90
minute tape and you're like we just
gonna see which part i like we're gonna
just and they they wouldn't have any
bodies done back then no it was real
[ __ ] was just natural
[Laughter]
and it was like the same it was like the
same four dudes in every movie it was
like god damn this dude's [ __ ] every
[ __ ]
and it also depended on which category
you were watching
cause like
peter peter north was [ __ ] all the
white chicks and then shawn michaels
my [ __ ] uncle luke though remember
lexington steele parker look was the
[ __ ]
[Music]
i don't know there was shawn michaels
uh [ __ ] i know who you're talking about
what happened to mr marcus no mr marcus
is that him
mr marcus remember mr marcus i don't
remember mr marcus yo
what about that [ __ ] who was cracking
eggs on bitch's blood
oh brush my [ __ ]
hey listen you can say [ __ ] with bp
brian
he turned out lawrence fishburne's
daughter [ __ ] not [ __ ] not [ __ ]
with bp blood hey come on when you start
cracking eggs
listen we both live in the valley we're
both familiar with uh asian-owned donut
shops right you go to the donut shop an
asian owns it usually here in the valley
right
so i go to the donut shop
and who's in line brian pumper bp north
north hollywood right
this is around the time my wife realized
how much of a piece of [ __ ] i was
because i recognized a male porn star
and she was like wait a minute
she's like i was like why i'm pumper i
see you bro and she's like who's that a
rapper i said nah nah he's a porn star
she was like
she was like wait why do you know the
dude's names i'm like you wouldn't
understand
you wouldn't understand anyway i said i
had to say brian popper got his orange
juice and his donut
and he went outside and he got in his
1998 nissan sentra
and this wasn't a nice nissan sentra by
the way this is like 2019.
this was the most beat down
nissan sentra of all time and that's not
the worst part he a real [ __ ] no no no
this guy
he had to be living out of this sentra
it was packed like tweaker pack and you
know how you'd be knowing tweakers and
their cars have all kinds of [ __ ] in
them this [ __ ] there was not an
inch left in this car that wasn't full
of
said damn
brent but he still had the fake jewels
on and he had lugs on him he was shining
oh the look he had lugs
in 2019
but y'all remember the johnny blaze
hoodies of course johnny blaze that was
my kid [ __ ] junior high sixth grade
lugs with the johnny blaze when you had
the lugs you had the [ __ ] echo
back when echo was fire now echo was lit
back academics triple five soul bro
come on bro
[ __ ] on my mama i forgot the other one
how you saying nietzsche
yeah aborix the average leathers are
coming back they are coming back i still
got two of them they're vintage i'm
thinking about selling them on ebay
they're also like five eggs remember
iceberg though iceberg of course with
the with the [ __ ] with tweety bird
and and sylvester
iceberg was lit
you had burger you was him [ __ ] iceberg
was that [ __ ] where you're rich for sure
like oh you got iceberg on you must have
some money because that [ __ ] was like a
hundred dollars a t-shirt and it was
just tweety bird
they sleep on iceberg blood paper x was
a [ __ ]
though it sucks because i have a wreck
[ __ ] but it's all like dude i was in
high school five minutes
of course
supreme
the original supreme it was dada supreme
da da that's some la [ __ ] that's some
west coast [ __ ]
didn't they give game his own shoe
wasn't that his shoes
i know that guys they did get with the
spinners
[Music]
the trail spinner shoes
god damn they were ugly but lugs
remember when they i think what where
lugs went wrong is when
birdman got a pair yeah with birdman it
was over i was like well these well
these are done no it was over with
bourbon before birdman loves was lit you
had him it was legitimate
the wallabies [ __ ]
the birdman
they that that killed the lugs for sure
funk flex had lugs
all right we gotta switch the subject
cause nigga's gonna be like [ __ ] how
old is these [ __ ] man
[Laughter]
i'm trying to think lugs
what else was hard back then
okay swiss was a little bit of classics
yeah that's the classic you come with
the classic low-key drake's new nikes
look like k-swisses low-key
oh my god a little k-swiss inspired you
see my [ __ ] tigers the waves
the wavy baby so his shoes look like if
you took shrooms and looked at vans yeah
the wavy baby they're sooner they i
heard that i need to give me a pair
[ __ ] before they make it before you
can't get them i need i need to get me
up here you got a relationship with
tiger my dog tiger can i get it yeah i
mean i need like size nina give me
righteous please immediately um said not
for sure i function with him every time
we you know we ain't got like like [ __ ]
just best of friend relationship every
time we bump into each other it's a guy
supporting who would you say is your uh
closest rapper friend that is the truth
that's big breath like that [ __ ] just
all the good game isn't wisdom and
they're gonna fly down on me right now
and they're gonna fly now he's the best
and [ __ ] take my daughters to chuck e
cheese [ __ ] something happened to me uh
he just that's a real a real just real
rare one super super uh
great guy i [ __ ] with you
that's why i [ __ ] with you bro you look
like you'll play some mazzy and then one
of the suckers blood right after i would
not
no i'm pretty tapped in with all of your
politicians
i appreciate you yeah yeah yeah
yeah no there's
i'm fully aware of the uh
there's certain people i wouldn't have
on my podcast i know what
and they've tried to come on
and and by the way i'm not talking about
filthy because filthy i've known for a
very long time and i feel like
you guys had a very peaceful on wax
issue now you have some other [ __ ] on
some other [ __ ]
filthy's my guy so you know he's on the
show but there's other you know from
that from where you're from and hey now
you're a real [ __ ] nah bro you're my
you're my guy now we locked in come on
man hey hey there's certain people i
just won't have on the show period based
on my friendships you know straight up
real one hey but that [ __ ] blue face
came on here [ __ ] and called you uh
what are you calling dj head
[Laughter]
i was like bro i've known you forever
i've literally booked him like 10 times
and there was i'm like bro we've hung
out like
dj head looks like a african american
ninja turtle like what are we doing here
nah that's what i need i love head
and i love i love blue face and uh yeah
that was fun but yeah man nah i
appreciate you coming on the show when
is the album coming album on the way
that [ __ ] on the freeway on the
freeway the roddy record is out yeah
that mf riding record shout out riley
real [ __ ] yeah i'm seeing me knock that
[ __ ] out pull it up to the video
video gangsta man i'm saying uh yeah
that [ __ ] should drop in like 30
days in the wake up or something right
yeah
30 days in the wake up we putting it
together i'm saying you got the name yet
uh
we could by the way we could tuck this
until like i don't know if a couple
weeks if you want nah for sure not the
name out there untreated trauma
untreated no no i was about to say i
think that's is in that i got it
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
not beyond bulletproof yeah i'm saying
look you seen that
both of these albums are already out are
we making sure you all go
so you're telling me you went all the
way to cmg just to put a deluxe out of
an album that's already out guys
i'm [ __ ] around
guilty survivor's guilt survivors guild
man [ __ ] feel guilty for being one of
the last survivors that is gangster [ __ ]
so yeah i'm saying uh you know
everything i come with gotta have a st
you gotta have a type of some type of
spiritual feel to it is there there's a
cmg compilation
uh yeah that [ __ ] on the way
yeah i just i just jumped on some
gangster [ __ ] too
uh
hell yeah you already know i had um
heard you say that you were like pretty
tapped in at the i was at the press
conference and i want to say
you and estg were pretty tapped in with
each other prior to uh and then of
course doug right most definitely i was
definitely uh locked in with them before
before the signing my [ __ ] uh
youngster too black youngster that's my
dog he's so funny yeah i'm saying you
know we we we put out a little project
before i've totally lost count of the
rand i forgot you had a pro a project
with gunplay until like a month ago i
was like oh [ __ ]
i forgot about this [ __ ] just be
working work work work work work you
know what i'm saying uh consistency i
remember somebody telling me consistency
is key and that [ __ ] paid off in a major
way straight up there it is man well i
appreciate you coming on the show
uh the new album survivor's guilt
survivor's guild make sure y'all tapped
hopefully it'll be out in the next 30
days 30 days in the wake up so that's 31
days
yeah 30 days in a wake up is this true
on the freeway okay
for sure if dave if dave says it's true
oh yeah confirmation man you know i'm
saying me what's it like having a
superstar manager now
man that [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] be trying to
outshine me with the jewelry and [ __ ]
[ __ ] be in the club [ __ ] i'm saying me
they got all the baddest [ __ ] in this
section and [ __ ] yeah i'm saying i'm on
the stage ain't nothing like the dave
[ __ ] glow up bro you seen it it's
i've seen it with my own eyes i ain't
waiting we're gonna get into that where
did we go get it i got lost the weight
cause i got that he got a
there it is man mozzie appreciate you
coming through appreciate you brother